[Música]
hoy en día escuchamos demasiado el
denominador de importancia de la
participación ciudadana pero alguna vez
hemos analizado lo que esto significa o
significaría si en verdad nos
organizáramos porque solemos
emocionarnos actuar a corto plazo y
después olvidamos el por qué comenzamos
y nos desconectamos de la realidad a la
que como seres humanos aspiramos y
pasamos de lo que debería me gustaría
preguntarte cuántas cosas has iniciado
una clase de baile y el gimnasio retomar
clases de idiomas y después lo dejas
incluso esta charla es parte de la
participación activa a fin de conectar e
inspirar cuando me extendía en la
invitación de inmediato sabía cuál es el
mensaje que deseaba compartir pero en el
transcurso de los días algunos de los
comentarios fueron así este tema está de
moda pero si está de moda porque no
todos lo seguimos el desarrollo
sostenible
el concepto de desarrollo sostenible no
es realmente nuevo data de 1987 en el
informe final de la comisión mundial del
medioambiente y desarrollo la gravedad y
complejidad hacen que sea un tema
latente hoy en día que no está
recibiendo la atención el desarrollo
sostenible se define como aquel que
satisface las necesidades de la
generación presente sin poner en peligro
la capacidad de las generaciones futuras
para satisfacer sus propias necesidades
es decir que tú y yo trabajemos hoy para
un futuro próspero
que ha llegado como ciudadanos del mundo
queremos dejar cuando tenemos datos
alarmantes de nuestro país tales como
los habitantes de mexico producen en
promedio 1.3 kilogramos de basura por
persona cada día más que cualquier otro
país en américa latina o que de acuerdo
con la ocde cerca del 73 por ciento de
la población padece obesidad o que 38
mil kilos de comida es desperdiciada
cada minuto que podría alimentar a 25.5
millones de personas lo cual también
trae implicaciones económicas y
ambientales
todo lo anterior nos engloba a todos
porque llevamos a cabo una actividad
llamada consumo el consumo es parte de
nuestra vida diaria todos los días
estamos comprando algo es una mezcla de
placer ocio y diversión pero el problema
radica cuando los recursos disponibles
se hacen escasos a medida que la
población siga aumentando se espera que
para 2030 seamos más de 8.600 millones
de personas somos compradores
compulsivos que no nos interesa en lo
más mínimo saber de dónde proviene mi
producto estamos tan desconectados que
no sabemos que esto puede llegar o más
bien proviene de esto
necesitamos hacer las preguntas
difíciles a las personas sindicadas
preguntas como de dónde viene cómo se
produce qué daños secundarios causa mi
salud es realmente sostenible desde el
agua que bebemos ya que en teoría es el
nutriente más poderoso que ponemos en
nuestro cuerpo es increíble y tan loco
que la bebemos a diario está tan clorada
y nadie habla sobre eso piensa que
aproximadamente 70% de tu cuerpo estado
es decir consumimos a diario cosas
antinaturales un millón de botellas por
minuto
esa es la tasa de consumo de botellas de
plástico desechables de un solo uso
cuando haya terminado esta charla serán
más de 10 millones el mundo ha cambiado
y aquellos en nosotros que vemos más
allá de nuestra frontera estamos del
lado correcto de la historia necesitamos
acelerar el cambio positivo para
garantizar calidad de vida en todos los
niveles estos sueños están en nuestras
manos por lo cual necesitamos ser parte
del cambio somos una sociedad
interconectada e intergeneracional
vivimos en una época en la cual todos
podemos ser escuchados tenemos ejemplos
como el de greta tamberg una joven
activista de 17 años que movilizó e
inspiró a todo el mundo porque usó su
voz y por tanto movilizó no sólo a corto
sino a largo plazo
es probable que todos queramos ayudar
pero no sabemos cómo bueno hay una
manera de hacerlo y es a través de la
agenda 2030 que contiene 17 objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible la cual fue
adoptada en la cumbre mundial sobre el
desarrollo sostenible por la asamblea
general de la organización de las
naciones unidas el 25 de septiembre de
2015 donde 193 países miembros tomaron
el compromiso de cumplir siendo méxico
uno de ellos es un plan de acción a
largo plazo a favor de las personas del
planeta y la prosperidad en sus 17
objetivos y 169 metas de carácter
integrado indivisible en donde se
conjugan las tres dimensiones del
desarrollo sostenible crecimiento
económico e inclusión social y
sustentabilidad ambiental donde además
se busca fortalecer el estado de derecho
la transparencia y la rendición de
cuentas asimismo la participación social
para promover el desarrollo de todas las
personas
necesitamos enfrentar estos retos a un
escala global y de manera sistemática
movilizar y actuar hoy el movimiento
está en todas partes al igual que la
información por lo cual no hay excusas
ya estamos en todas partes solo tenemos
que organizarnos inmovilizarlos
comportarnos de manera altruista debe
ser parte de nuestra vida diaria ya que
el activismo es la única manera
ciudadanos globales
un ciudadano global no es el que ha
viajado más ni tampoco el que ordena
artículos al otro extremo del mundo sino
que a aquel que es consciente de lo que
sucede a su alrededor y hace algo por
cambiar
unirte al barco de la solidaridad cuesta
un boleto de compromiso y disposición
la agenda 2030 es una visión de futuro
sumamente ambiciosa y transformativa
donde todas las formas de vida pueden
prosperar nunca hasta ahora se habían
comprometido los líderes del mundo con
una acción y un empeño común en pro de
una agenda de políticas tan amplia y
universal quienes son dueños de la
historia nosotros y el poder nos
pertenece como ciudadanos aquí
pertenecemos es nuestra casa la que está
en juego de tal manera que salvar el
mundo comienza contigo en cuerpo mente y
alma si bien es cierto la agenda se
encuentra en todos los niveles pero
también cada ciudadano puede hacer algo
para lograr un desarrollo sostenible una
acción hecho por todos traerá consigo
cambios reales
hoy en día nos dimos cuenta que tan
importante somos todos y como nuestro
comportamiento individual hace la
diferencia sin importar en qué parte del
mundo te encuentres ni tampoco su
dimensión geográfica geopolítica aquí
todos importamos por lo cual debemos
adoptar un nuevo estilo de vida un
estilo de vida sostenible comenzar a
valorar qué actividades llevamos a cabo
cada día y que podemos modificar dejar
de hacer o evitar aspirar a ser sus
ciudades sostenibles puede ser una
realidad
necesitamos ser personas dispuestos a
levantar la vista de su celular la
agenda 2030 es la hoja de ruta trazada
para lograr cada objetivo tiene metas e
indicadores que nos permiten medir los
avances estamos en la década de la
acción por lo cual nunca hasta ahora
nuestra participación haber sido tan
importante todos podemos actuar por uno
o más veces tenemos avances
considerables y miles de personas que se
unieron y movilizar como lo es el chef
josé andrés de webs entra aquí quien
trabaja a lo largo de américa para
distribuir comida fresca
unidades que necesitan de apoyo está
activo en docenas de ciudades y provee a
cerca de 150.000 comidas frescas cada
día donde la comida también es un agente
de cambio o por ejemplo el joven
estudiante de segundo año de medicina
malone muy buen de de saint georges
landing quien diseñó y escribió el
manual mind the gap que será publicado
en los siguientes meses de cómo detectar
enfermedades en la piel de color ya que
sólo se enseña cómo detectar ciertos
síntomas en la piel blanca encuentra tu
bandera tu causa y defiende la los
superhéroes existe y los son diferentes
a como solemos imaginar los claro está
que no usan capa nosotros podemos
hacerlo
tan solo piensa en ese alguien que te
inspira el mundo está lleno de ellos a
pesar que la mayoría de las veces suelen
ser héroes anónimos debemos despertar y
tomar la oportunidad en el rol que cada
uno tiene su alrededor un buen amigo un
buen ciudadano que apoya y es consciente
de lo que sucede tu haces la diferencia
decídete despierta y despierta solidario
tras la conducta de cada uno depende del
destino de todos es tiempo de impactar
generaciones y no es a través de la
huella ecológica el poder nos pertenece
pero la sed nos corresponde
y tú estás dispuesto a cambiar tu estilo
de vida porque la tarea es no dejar a
nadie atrás
[Música]